The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
last time, we started
to think about sampling.
And that's what I want
to finish up today.
I think sampling is a
very important issue.
It's one of the
strengths of this course
because we can think about on
equal footing the way signals
work in a CT system, or in a
DT system, when the signals are
CT, when the signals are DT.
And specifically, when
you convert between them.
Converting between them,
like we saw last time, that's
a very important process because
many of the kinds of signals
that we want to think
about occur in physical--
have a physical origin
where they are naturally
continuous time or continuous
space kinds of signals,
but we would like to use
inexpensive digital electronics
in order to process them.
So it's important to understand
how we can take a CT signal
and represent the information
that's there in a DT manner.
And it's completely remarkable
that you can even do that.
CT signals are in some sense
arbitrarily more complicated
than DT signals.
DT signals only exist at
integer multiples of time,
at integer values of time.
CT signals, in principle,
can do anything
between two consecutive
samples of a DT signal.
So in some sense, they're
arbitrarily more complicated.
So it's kind of
remarkable at all
that we can talk meaningfully
about how you can represent
the information that's in a
CT system with a DT equivalent
system.
And the point is, and the
reason we're doing it now
in this part of the
course, is that by thinking
about Fourier transforms,
everything's very simple.
Something that could be
conceptually quite complicated
is in fact, extremely
simple to think about.
So last time, we saw that the
way to think about the signal,
if you want to sample
it, if you want
to convert a CT
signal to a DT signal,
the way to think about it is
to think about the Fourier
transform.
So then, the example that
we talked about last time,
you think about a
CT signal, x of t.
You think about its sample
is taken uniformly in time.
And then in order to think about
the information and whether
or not you've captured it
all, the question is, can you
reconstruct the original
thing that you started
with from the samples only?
OK.
Well, in general, no.
So what we're really asking
is, what are the rules,
what are the conditions
under which you can do that?
And are they useful
conditions or not?
So the first way you can
think about taking the samples
and turning them back into
a continuous time signal
is something that we called
impulse reconstruction.
In impulse reconstruction,
we substitute
for every sample an impulse
appropriately located in time
and appropriately
scaled in amplitude.
The appropriate
scale and amplitude
is that you take the samples
and you weight the impulses.
You weight the impulse
at the n-th time step
by the sample value for time n.
And you put the n-th
one at time nt, n cap t.
So impulse reconstruction.
It's really easy.
Take all the
samples that you got
by uniform sampling, substitute
for every sample one impulse--
appropriately timed,
appropriately weighted.
OK, that's great.
It's especially
nice because there's
a simple Fourier representation
for that process.
That process, if we think
about just taking x of t
and turning it into this
impulse reconstruction,
that impulse reconstruction
is precisely the same
as if I had multiplied
the original signal x of t
by an impulse train.
Impulse is separated by
capital T unit height.
So that means the transformation
can be thought of in terms
of Fourier transforms
as the convolution
of the original spectrum,
the original Fourier
transform, with the Fourier
transform of the impulse train,
which is just another
impulse train.
So the rule is you can
represent all the information
in the signal if the signal
started out being bandlimited.
OK.
If this signal had a region
of frequency over which it is
non-0 and for the rest of
frequency the signal is 0,
then when you do the aliasing,
you can arrange the period
so that the aliased copy--
so that the convolved copies
don't overlap with each other.
OK.
So that was a simple
way of thinking about,
how much information
was in the samples,
by thinking about the
impulse reconstruction.
Of course, the signal that we
reconstruct by this convolution
process has multiple copies
of the same frequency content.
So we don't like that.
So you can throw away
those extra copies
by doing a low-pass
filtering operation.
And we call that
reconstruction-- the xr,
we call that the
bandlimited reconstruction.
It's like the impulse
reconstruction,
except that it's bandlimited.
OK.
So we think of two ways of
doing the reconstruction
from the samples--
the impulse reconstruction,
the bandlimited reconstruction.
And the key is the
sampling theorem.
The sampling theorem says that
if the original signal had
non-zero frequency content
over only some particular range
of frequencies, you can
sample fast enough so that you
can represent all of
the information that's
in the continuous time
signal with the samples.
OK.
Is that all clear?
The point is we're trying
to represent the information
in a CT signal using DT.
And that the Fourier transform
is a way to visualize when you
can do that and when
you cannot do that.
You still end up in
a physical system,
perhaps generating signals
whose frequency content
falls out of that range.
We saw an illustration
of that last time.
So for example,
if you were to try
to represent a signal
with this transform using
a sampling period t, so that
the impulses in frequency
were separated by
2 pi over t, which
happened to be less than
twice this distance,
then it would alias.
That's bad.
So we would typically
also include
an anti-aliasing filter,
pre-filter the signal
from physics, get
rid of the parts
that you know are going to be a
problem when you try to sample.
Then, go ahead and do
the regular sampling,
the regular uniform sampling,
the regular bandlimited
reconstruction.
And the signal that
you reconstruct
won't be an identical
copy, but it
will be as close as you can
given the sampling theorem.
OK.
So that's what we did last time.
What I want to do today is
think about some other issues
that come up when you try to
represent a continuous signal
in a discrete domain.
So in addition to thinking
about discretizing time,
we also have to think about
discretizing amplitude.
Because if we want to
represent a signal by bits--
so we have to represent
not only the time,
but also the amplitude in bits.
I'll talk about
several different kinds
of schemes for that.
In the simplest
kinds of schemes,
the code for the
representation in amplitude
is separately
derived from the code
for the representation in time.
So we can think of it as two
boxes, a sampling box followed
by a quantization box.
The first box, the sampling
box, takes the CT signal of time
and turns it into a DT signal.
The second box
takes the samples,
which have a continuous domain,
and turn them into samples
from a finite domain--
from a discrete domain.
OK.
So if you're doing that kind
of a quantization scheme,
then the thing you
have to think about
is how many bits
you're willing to use
to represent each sample.
I mean, this is the
simplest kind of a scheme
that you could use.
There's much more complicated
schemes by the end of the hour.
I'll tell you about
a scheme that is
much more efficient than this.
But this is kind
of the base level.
This is where you would start.
So if you wanted to
represent an amplitude
in a discrete
representation, one way
you could do about it-- one
way you could think about it
is to think about the map
between the continuous values
that the sample could acquire
and map it to a discrete output
set.
So for example, if you were
using 2 bits per sample,
then you might represent any
voltage between minus 1/2
and 1/2 by some code 0, 1.
Any voltage that's in the range
1/2 to 1 as the code 1, 0.
And any voltage in the range
minus 1 to minus 1/2 as 0, 0.
That would be a way of
taking a continuous range
of possible amplitudes
and turning it
into a discrete number
using just 2 bits.
Obviously if you use more bits,
you can get greater precision.
What's showed below here
is, what if my signal was
a function of time--
looked like the red waveform.
My discrete representation might
look like the blue waveform,
right?
If I'm imagining that
I only have 2 bits,
then I only have 3
possible symmetric outputs.
So that might be
represented by the blue.
And the difference between
the red and the blue
is showed in the green.
And as you can see as
you go to more bits,
you obviously get errors--
the green signal as it's
getting smaller, right?
So the key thing then
is, how many bits
do you need for the thing that
you're trying to represent?
So I like hearing.
So I'll illustrate the number
of bits by thinking about sound.
You can hear sounds that range
in amplitude over a range
of about a million to 1.
So if you were to put a person
with good ears-- not me,
one of you.
If you were to put one
of you into a quiet room
and let you sit there until
you adapted, and then played
the faintest sound that
you could possibly hear,
then multiplied by
10, multiplied by 10,
multiplied by 10, you could
make it a million times
more intense in pressure.
You could amplify the
pressure by a million
before it'd start to hurt.
It wouldn't damage yet.
You'd have to go
to about 8 million,
and then it would
start to damage.
But you could do about a
million to 1 over the range
from just barely audible
to starts to hurt.
So how many bits would
it take to do that range?
So how many bits would it take?
Raise your hands.
Show me a number of fingers.
How many bits would it take
to represent a million to 1?
OK.
100%.
I think it's 100%.
So easy question.
So if you use 1 bit, you
can represent 2 levels.
If you use 2 bits, you can do 4.
8, 16, 32.
By the time you get to 10
bits, you're up to 1,024.
By the time you're up to
20 bits, you're up to 1,024
squared.
OK, 20 bits ought to do it.
And in fact, 20 bits--
if you were to buy a
high-end audio system,
it would be 24-bits.
There are people who
claim you need 32.
I think they're kind of crazy.
But a high-end audio system
would be a 24-bit system.
Now, if you were to listen
to sort of CD quality,
CDs are 16 bits.
So there are
people, even me, who
claim that they can tell the
difference between a concert
and a CD representation
of a concert.
OK.
So there might be some
limitations of representing
audio with 16 bits.
But what I'll show
you is a demo where
I've showed the
same piece of music
at 16 bits, 8 bits, 6
bits, 4 bits, 2 bits, and 1
bit per sample, so that you get
the idea of what a quantization
error sounds like.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I
think the difference
between a concert and a CD,
it's mainly because [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: There's lots
of things that are different.
And you're raising
a very good point.
You certainly don't get the
spatial aspects of a concert.
We try to fake you out.
We put false cues
in, so the violin
sounds like it's
on the right side.
But those are all fake, usually.
Well, they're not
completely fake.
And we have stereo.
And we have 5 plus 1.
So we have lots of
different representations.
But if you were to imagine
listening in a concert
monaurally.
So plug your ear, clamp
your head so you can't turn,
and compare that to listening
with a mono headphone, that's
what I'm talking about.
So if you didn't get spatial
cues and things like that.
OK.
So the issue then is to
listen to different levels
of quantization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DENNIS FREEMAN: So it's
actually kind of amazing, right?
You can sort of tell what the
piece is the whole way down
to-- how many of you could
tell the difference between 16
and 8?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: How
many of you could tell
the difference between 8 and 6?
How many of you could tell
any difference whatever?
Just joking.
What's the difference
in the sound quality?
What's the effect of quantizing?
AUDIENCE: Fuzziness
in the background.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Kind of fuzzy.
So could you simulate
the fuzzy sound?
What would you do if
you wanted to sort
of simulate the fuzzy sound?
Besides, of course,
quantizing, which
would be a perfect simulation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Noise.
It kind of sounds hissy.
[HISSING] It sounds
kind of noisy and that's
kind of the point.
And that's an important
issue because it
affects how much music you
can put on any given medium.
So for example, in a
CD, CDs are 16 bits
per sample, 2 channels,
44.1 kilosamples per second,
60 seconds per minute.
74 minutes is a typical
recording time for a CD.
So you end up with
about a gigabyte.
And that's what
you can put on one
of those little plastic things.
If you were willing to live
with 8-bit instead of 16-bit,
you could obviously
put on 148 minutes.
So people don't make
these decisions lightly.
It's how many people
do you make angry
for one reason or
the other, right?
You can make them angry because
they don't get much music
or you can make them
angry because they
don't get high quality, right?
So you get to sort
of trade-off the kind
of people who hate you.
But that's the kind of idea.
So if you have a
piece of plastic
on which you can
put 1 gigabyte, you
have to think about how
you're going to represent it.
And it matters how
frequently you sample.
And also, with what quantization
you represent each sample.
Same sort of thing
happens for pictures.
Here's a relatively
high-quality picture,
where it's 280 by 280 pixels.
And it's an 8-bit
representation in amplitude.
The point's just that
the kinds of things
that happen when you
quantize a picture
are very similar to the same
sorts of things that happen
when you quantized audio.
So if we take this picture
and compare it to--
substitute for each
pixel a quantized version
of the amplitude.
Quantized here to 8
bits and here to 7 bits.
You might be able to
see the difference.
If I come up really
close, I can certainly
see quantization effects.
If I drop the right one
to 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
OK.
So here is 8 bits and 4 bits.
Remember that when we thought
about the audio example,
it sounded fuzzy.
It sounded hissy.
[HISSING] What's the
effect of quantizing here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Sharp and--
say again?
AUDIENCE: The contrast.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Well,
there's certainly a problem.
So both of these pictures
have high contrast, right?
How would I see contrast
in the pictures?
Contrast refers to
having big steps,
step changes in brightness.
So like, I might see a high
contrast between this petal
and that leaf.
And I still have a high
contrast at the analogous place
over here.
So there is some
contrast effects.
A little more
subtly, the contrast
affects how well you
see the quantization.
So if I changed
the picture to have
different amounts
of contrast, I could
effect whether you could see
the quantization well or poorly.
So in audio, the
effect of quantizing--
as I quantized more
and more and more,
I caused more and more hiss
[HISSING] in the background.
What's the effect here?
What's the effect of quantizing?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You have less
grays to work with.
DENNIS FREEMAN: I
have fewer grays.
AUDIENCE: So 1-bit was
just black and white.
So as you increase bits,
you get more grays--
DENNIS FREEMAN: Absolutely.
Could you give me sort of
a qualitative assessment
of the kinds of errors
that you see here
compared to the kinds of errors
that you don't see there?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: There's banding.
Why would there be banding?
Nobody said the audio
sounded like it was banded.
We just don't hear
that way, right?
Even though we're doing
a similar process,
why do we see
banding in pictures?
What's causing the banding?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yeah, exactly.
So the pixels that are nearby--
so take the pixels here, which
came from pixels over here.
They have nearly
the same gray value,
but the quantizer is
making up its mind
at a very precise level.
It's deciding, oh, you're
between these two levels.
Turn into this number.
If you're between
these two levels,
turn into this other number.
So you get the bands
because there's
correlations in the brightnesses
of pixels that are nearby.
So you get this
banding thing that
can be objectionable whenever
the quantization is not
sufficient.
OK.
So one way you can reduce
that is called dithering.
Dithering means add noise.
So that's kind of weird.
So I want to get
rid of the bands.
So what do I do?
I take every pixel.
And before I quantize
it, I add noise to it.
Then even if the pixels came
from a region that were nearly
the same amplitude
to start with,
each individual pixel gets
a different amount of noise
so they quantize differently.
And if I choose my
noise in a clever way,
I could use my noise to be
plus or minus 1 quantum.
So I could choose a
random number generator
that gave me numbers
that were evenly
distributed over the
range minus 1/2 quantum
to plus 1/2 quantum.
And if I do that,
then I can generate
a picture that is
quantized but was dithered
before it was quantized.
So the two pictures are
both quantized at the level
of 7 bits, but the
one on the right
had dither added to it first.
So I'm adding noise before
I do the quantization.
And you can't see too much at 7.
6, 5, 4, 3.
OK.
So what's the difference
between the two?
Well, over here
I had these bands
because the amplitudes
were such that they all got
converted into the same output.
The bands have
disappeared over there.
2.
Even 1 the bands have
disappeared, right?
But that's obviously
not a good solution.
So what's wrong with dither?
AUDIENCE: Noisy.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Noisy, yeah.
I'm kind of going back
to the hiss thing, right?
Now, I've taken a picture
that had had bands
and I've turned it into a
picture that looks noisy.
There's a way to think
about how the noise works.
Imagine that I had a
smoothly-varying signal showed
in blue that was being turned
from a continuous range
of amplitudes into a
discrete range of amplitudes.
So let's represent the
discrete amplitudes
by the dashed red lines.
Then, the signal
that I might quantize
could look like the red signal.
And that's a very
graphic representation
of where the bands come from.
So the bands come from the
fact that the original signal
sliced through a small
number of quantized outputs.
Everybody see where
the bands are?
Then, if I add dither,
I can think about--
so this transformation
from blue to red,
I can think about that
as being y equals Q of x.
So x is the blue line,
Q of x is the red line.
Down here, what
I've done is I've
taken x and added noise to it.
Then, I ran it through
the same quantizer.
And you can see that
I've broken up the bands,
but you can see that I've
added a bunch of noise.
So there's a slightly
more clever thing
that we can do that's
called Robert's technique.
Larry Roberts was a
masters student here.
He was here before
I was here, which
is kind of a remarkable thing.
But they actually wrote thesis
back then and they used paper.
And you can go to the
library and it's still there.
So Larry thought of
a method for dealing
with this where what you do is
you take the original signal x,
you add n to it and
quantize it, but then you
subtract n back off.
And that's called
Robert's technique.
And that's illustrated
by this transformation.
The good thing about this
transformation is that this--
so here, the quantization
error was clearly
correlated with the signal.
That's what banding is, right?
Something about the signal
turned into something
about the error.
Here, the error is still
correlated with the signal.
The correlation is
less obvious, right?
But here is a range of
errors that are all positive.
And here is a range of
errors that are all negative.
So the errors are
still correlated
with the original signal.
So the result-- and when
you do Robert's technique,
you destroy the correlation.
So with Robert's technique, you
end up with-- it's still noisy.
Because after all,
I added noise to it.
But I've added it
in a very clever way
that removes the correlation
between the error
and the signal.
And the result is that
the noise seems less.
So if you compare
6 bits with dither
to 6 bits with Robert's
method, both pictures
are represented by 6 bits.
5 bits, 5 bits.
4, 3.
So the interesting thing
is that the Robert's method
looks like less noise.
It's mathematically not.
Mathematically, you can
show that Robert's technique
has the same energy in the
noise as was in the ditherer
technique.
If you just calculate
the energy in the error,
they're identical.
But in Robert's technique,
he destroys the correlation
and that makes the
noise seem smaller.
It's like physically
less objectionable.
What's the problem with
Robert's technique?
If I told you to
implement a scheme
that quantized according
to Robert's technique.
And say you're here and you're
supposed to quantize a message,
send it over the ethernet,
and receive it in California.
And you're only supposed
to be sending, say,
a 6-bit representation instead
of a 16-bit representation.
What's hard about Robert's
technique compared to dither?
Quantizing is easy, right?
I take my 16-bit CD.
I take off the first sample.
I quantize it.
I send it across the internet.
I take off my second sample.
I quantize it.
I send those 6 bits over
the internet, et cetera.
Dither is sort of
the same thing.
I pick up the first sample.
I add noise to it.
I quantize it.
I send those 6 bits
over the internet.
What's the hard
part of Robert's?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
send the noise too?
DENNIS FREEMAN: I have
to send the noise, too.
I have to know the
precise value of the noise
that I added to sample n, so
I can subtract it back out.
So Robert's technique
says, I take the value x
and I add some
amount of noise n.
End was a random number.
I chose it by throwing
a die or something.
I quantize that, and then
I subtract that same number
back out.
Well, that number has
to be precise compared
to the quantization levels.
So for example, people
would normally use--
if I'm doing 16-bit audio,
people would normally
use a 16-bit
representation for n,
which means that I take a
16-bit number off the CD.
I take a random number.
I add it, quantize it.
And now, I can send
the 6-bit number.
But in order for that guy
to reproduce the answer,
he has to know n too.
Everybody see that?
So the problem is, how
do you send the noise?
And the trick is
that we use something
called pseudo random noise.
Pseudo random noise
is an algorithm
that generates a sequence of
numbers that looks random,
but they were made
algorithmically.
So you can independently
manufacture the same sequence
here and there.
That way, if you're
using the same--
if you pre-agree that
you're going to use the same
algorithm, you can independently
generate the same sequence
of n's.
OK.
Yeah, so I jumped
back to explain--
OK.
So the point is that just
like in audio, in pictures
it's important how many
bits you quantize to.
That affects drastically the
performance of communications
or storage devices.
How many pictures can
you store someplace?
you put on your iPhone?
So all of that
matters quite a bit.
And the code that you
use is very important.
And you're not limited to just--
I have two more examples.
So the simplest possible
schemes are the ones
that I've showed
so far where you
think about the sampling in
time and the quantization
in amplitude as
separate processes.
You don't have to do that.
In fact, you can get
much higher performance
if you combine the two.
So the first combination
I want to think about
is trading off
precision for speed.
And that's something that we
call progressive refinement.
The idea is, imagine
that I want to make
a digital representation of all
the paintings in the Louvre.
OK.
It doesn't make sense to do
200 by 200 at 6-bit resolution
if you were looking at
pictures in the Louvre.
That doesn't make
any sense, right?
You would like to see a
high-resolution version.
OK.
And now you're a
user, and what you'd
like to do is leaf
through them and find
photos of something or other.
Scenes of some type.
OK.
Well if you've got a
high-resolution representation
and you're trying to thumb
through a lot of images.
The problem is, if
each one is represented
with high resolution,
that can take a long time.
So if you didn't do
something clever,
basically you would have to
download the Louvre before you
could do your search.
So the idea in
progressive refinement
is first send me a
crude representation.
And if I haven't
changed in my browser,
if I'm still looking at the same
picture three seconds later,
continue to load
the information that
makes the picture
increasingly precise.
Give me a crude representation
as soon as you can.
And then if I sit there, give me
a more refined representation.
But if I lead to someplace
else, stop downloading that one
and give me a crude
representation
of the new place.
That's the idea.
So the way you can do that
is with discrete sampling.
I started with a digital
representation of a painting
in the Louvre.
Maybe it was 20,000 by 20,000
with 24 levels of color--
some huge picture.
So what I'll do
is I'll sample it.
But this time, it's DT sampling.
DT sampling-- you'll be
completely shocked to hear
this--
is completely analogous
to CT sampling.
It's almost the same thing.
That shouldn't be too
big of a surprise,
all of the different
transforms, all
the different Fourier
representations that we looked
at, are almost the same thing.
So DT sampling turns out
to work almost exactly
like CT sampling.
So think about what you would do
if you wanted to take a picture
and represent it with
a factor of 3 fewer
pixels in the horizontal
and a factor of 3 fewer
pixels in the vertical.
Well, you would sample it.
In CT, we would think about
multiplying the CT signal
x of t by an impulse train.
Here, we use a
unit sample train.
So we think about an
original signal x of n.
And we think about
a sampling waveform
that's now at an infinite
unit-sampled training.
We used to use an
infinite impulse train,
now we're using an infinite
unit-sampled train.
So we preserve
every third sample
and throw away the ones between.
So that's a way of
generating a new picture that
only has one third of
the information that
was in the original picture.
And as I said before, it
should come as no surprise
that the math for thinking
about this sampling process
is virtually
identical to the math
that you need to think about
the CT sampling problem.
In particular, the key is
to think about the Fourier
representation.
If this were the
original Fourier signal,
if this were the Fourier
representation of this signal,
we have to think about
the Fourier representation
for the sampling signal, the
infinite unit-sampled train.
An infinite unit-sampled
train, not surprisingly,
the transform of that's going
to be an infinite impulse train.
All DT signals are
periodic in 2 pi.
That's a property of DT signals.
That's a property
of the unit circle.
So we're not surprised to
see that this signal was
periodic in 2 pi.
This signal is also
That's because it's DT.
But it's also periodic
in one third of that.
That's because of
the periodicity here.
OK.
So if we had had a sample
at each one of these,
then the base periodicity
would have been 2 pi.
But here, because
of the periodicity
being 1 every third sample, we
get 3 times that many impulses.
So just like in CT
sampling, we think
about multiplying
the original waveform
by a sampling waveform that
preserves only the information
at the samples.
We do the same thing here.
Multiplication in time is
convolution in frequency.
So we take the original
signal, we convolve it,
and this is what comes out
of that sampling process.
We get the same rule
for the sampling theorem
that we got for CT.
This process has to be such that
when you do the convolution,
the resulting nearest
neighbors shouldn't overlap.
So there is a maximum frequency
for the discrete system,
just like there was a maximum
frequency for the CT system.
There's one more step.
Obviously, if I sample
the picture at the Louvre,
I don't want to send the 0's.
That doesn't make any sense.
So in order to not send
the 0's, I smash together
the non-0 samples.
That's illustrated here.
Smashing in time does
what in frequency?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Squish in
time, stretch in frequency.
They're reciprocal
spaces, right?
Frequency and time
are reciprocal spaces.
Smash in time,
stretch in frequency.
So the result is that when
you smash the 0 entries out
of the signal, you stretch
the frequency representation
by a factor of 3.
And when you stretch
by a factor of 3,
this peak, which
was at 1/3 of 2 pi,
moves the whole way out to 2 pi.
OK.
So the idea then is that I've
got this beautiful picture
in the Louvre.
Maybe.
In order to send a lower
resolution version of that,
what I do is I
low-pass filter it
because I don't want the
frequencies to alias.
So I low-pass filter it.
That gives me a representation
that I can then downsample.
OK.
So this had the same
size, but this one
has fewer high-frequency
components.
So I can downsample,
which gives me
something that
can be represented
in the squeezed version
with fewer pixels.
I did a downsample by a factor
of 2 in both, so that picture
has 1/4 the number
of pixels in it.
Then, I can low-pass filter
that one and downsample.
And low-pass filter
And I end up with a very
low-resolution image
of this beautiful scene
that I started with.
OK.
So that means that I start
with some number of pixels.
Here I have 1/4 as many.
Here I have 1/4 of that.
And here I have 1/4 of that.
So I have a fourth cubed the
original number of pictures.
So it will go 4 cubed faster.
So it'll take me a lot less
time to get the low-res picture.
So the result then--
skip this for the moment.
So here's my low-res picture.
With a lot of imagination, you
can clearly see what that is.
At the next level of
refinement, you get this.
By now, you're
tired so you flick
on something more interesting.
No.
You would continue to
look at this, right?
And finally, you get
the original picture.
So the idea then is that I
want to not only transmit.
But then the question is, how
many bits do I need to do this?
And the answer is that
having transmitted this,
I can use that information
to help me generate this.
OK.
So what I do, I run
the process backwards.
Let me back up.
So in order to go forwards, I
thought about squishing this
into a smaller representation.
Well, I can go backwards.
I can up-sample.
When I up-sample, all I do
is I take all the pictures
in the shrunken
version, I stretch them,
and I put 0's between them.
That gets me here.
But that's not
where I want to be.
I want to be up here.
So how do I go
from here to here?
So when I put the 0's in it.
So I started with this,
I put the 0's in it.
That stretched it in time.
That compressed it in frequency.
When I compress this
waveform into frequency,
this 2 pi peak ended
up at 2 pi over 3.
So now if I want to get back
to the original contribution,
I have to low-pass filter.
OK.
Everybody see what I'm doing?
So the final scheme
then is that--
whoops.
The final scheme
is that I low-pass
filter, downsample, low-pass,
downsample, low-pass,
downsample.
Downsample, I can up-sample
by putting 0's between all
the rows and columns.
Then, low-pass filter and
that gives me this picture.
So what I need to
do is also transmit
the high-pass information
that I threw away.
So if I separately
transmit this picture
in the high-pass
part of this picture,
then I can combine them
to get that picture.
And I don't actually need
to transmit this one.
So I don't need to
transmit this one either
because I can generate.
So I only need to
send this and this.
Then, I do the same thing here.
If I take this, I put 0's
between it, low-pass filter.
I can generate this picture,
so I don't need to send it.
But I do send this.
Then, I combine these
to get that recurse.
OK.
So the result is that I send--
so I don't send this,
but I do send this.
I don't send that because
I'm going to regenerate it.
I don't send that.
I do send this.
I only send this,
this, this, and that.
And that's enough information
to reconstruct the picture.
Right
And notice it has the hierarchy
that you would expect.
You start with a low-res.
It takes more bits
to make this one.
to make that one.
And it takes more
bits to make that one.
You're worse off
if you didn't do
something clever by-- so I'm
sending the full number of bits
here.
Then, I'm sending another 1/4.
And then, another 1/16.
Then, another 1/64.
So I'm sending about
33% more bits total.
But there's tricks.
The trick is that
the eye is less
sensitive to these
high frequencies
than it is to these.
So I really don't need to send
the same resolution for this.
So people use this all the time.
If you go to a slow
website, you may
notice that you get
that kind of low-res
morphing into a higher-res.
And that's exactly
this kind of a scheme.
But there are cleverer
things you can do.
So that's already pretty clever.
And that's already something
you see in today's technology,
but there are even cleverer
things that you can do.
And so the last thing I
want to talk about is JPEG.
99% of the images that you
download on the web are JPEG.
JPEG is a clever technique
that does quantization
in the Fourier domain.
And that's similar
to what you would
want to do in that
progressive refinement
because you would like
to separate the frequency
components and use less
resolution for the higher
frequency components because
you can't see them as well.
JPEG is a formalization
of that idea.
So this was made by
a joint photography
group that was very successful.
It has four layers of coding.
First thing you
worry about is color.
OK.
We think we see a
broad range of colors.
Wrong.
We only see three.
So you can throw away the
ones that we can't see.
So that's the first step is
taking advantage of the fact
that we really can't see
all the different colors.
We can really only
see three colors.
So there are tricks
that you can do
to make the person
think he's seeing
the exact shade of yellow,
which we don't see very well,
by mixing together a different
combination of red, green,
and blue.
So you get to move
the colors around.
And you can make it
perceptually indistinguishable,
but easier to code.
We won't talk about how
you do that, but it's
a very straightforward process
by which you start with one
picture and you change all
the colors to make them easier
to send.
OK.
So that's the color coding.
Then, they do a discrete
cosine transform,
which is really a kind
of Fourier series.
Then, they quantize the
Fourier series, the DCT.
And then, they code
the resulting sequence
using a lossless Huffman code.
So we'll talk about
the middle two steps
because that's the fun stuff.
That's the Fourier stuff.
So the way DCT works
is you take the image
and you break it into
8 by 8 pixel squares.
And then you do the same
processing on each 8 by 8.
So here is an example
of an 8 by 8 image.
This is a completely
trivial one where
I have linear taper from
black to white, linear taper
from black to
white, the product.
And all I want to think
about is, what's the DCT?
And why do they use a DCT
instead of a Fourier transform?
So just like you would expect
from the other two-dimensional
image processing, the examples
that we've talked about,
the way you do this is you
do the DCT on all the rows.
Then, you do the DCT
on all the columns.
And then you're done.
That's a two-dimensional DCT.
So here's an example.
What if I took my sample image,
which had this linear taper.
So if I think about
just one row and I
plot brightness on the
vertical, then this
might be my image right here.
And what I do is think about
periodically repeating it.
The original signal only
had 8 numbers in it.
I'm going to periodically
repeat it because then I
can take a Fourier series.
It's a periodic signal,
and it's a Fourier series.
The reason I do that is
that the Fourier series only
has 8 coefficients.
The Fourier series of
an eight-long sequence
has eight Fourier coefficients.
So the idea is that by
taking a signal that's
only 8 samples long--
I mean, the obvious
thing you could do
is take the eight-long signal
and take a discrete time
Fourier transform.
Problem with that is that
that's a continuous function
of omega over 2 pi, over
the entire unit circle.
So you take 8 samples and turn
it into a function of omega
which has lots of samples.
By thinking about the
8 samples as having
come from a periodic
extension, then I
don't get a continuous range
of frequencies between minus pi
to pi.
I get exactly 8 of
them, a0 through a7.
OK.
So the first step is to
do periodic extension
on the 8 samples.
Then, I can represent it
by 8 Fourier coefficients.
In the DCT, they almost do that.
But instead of writing down the
numbers 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Instead, they write 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
That seems like a
dumb thing to do.
I took an eight-long
sequence, which
could be represented
with 8 coefficients,
and I turned it into a
16-long sequence, which
now takes 16 coefficients.
Wow, that's brain dead.
Except that it's
actually very clever.
Of these two signals,
which has the higher
high-frequency content?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Sharp
drop, large amount
of high frequencies.
That's the trick.
So because there's a large
amount of high frequencies,
this signal is hard to
represent with Fourier series.
This signal is easier because
there's fewer high frequencies.
You need fewer of
those high frequencies
to do a good job of
representing the signal.
You can throw away the
high-frequency stuff
and nobody will notice.
OK.
So the idea then is that you
use this 16-long sequence,
but then you know that
whatever x of 8 was,
it's the same as x of 9
because you always repeat it.
And x of 7, that's
the same as x of 10.
So if you take
advantage of knowing
that there's a symmetry.
And if you notice,
they made it symmetric.
So there's an even-odd kind of
symmetry about a weird point.
It's off by 1/2, but there's
a symmetry this way, too.
If you take those two
things into account,
you can actually represent
the 16-length sequence
with 8 numbers.
That's the DCT.
It's exactly the
same as a Fourier,
except that we're taking
the 8 non-trivial numbers
and putting them together
in a funny periodic fashion.
That's what a DCT does.
And the point is the
DCT maps 8 real numbers,
which are these yn values.
It maps 8 real numbers
into 8 DCT coefficients.
And the DCT coefficients,
unlike the Fourier coefficients,
have real values.
So because of the trick
with all the symmetries
and all that sort of
stuff, they arrange
to make a transform
whose imaginary part
is guaranteed to be 0.
So there's no
information explosion
in going from the 8 to 16.
Here's the Fourier
representation
for a 2D picture.
The Fourier coefficients
are falling off like k.
Here's the DCT where they're
falling off like k squared.
And the point is you can throw
those away in the picture
and barely tell that
they're even there.
That they're even gone.
So what they do then is
they quantize the Fourier
coefficients at
different levels.
So you divide the 0,
0 coefficient by 16
and send the whole part.
You divide the 1, 0 by 11.
You divide this guy by 61, so
you use much less resolution
by a factor of 4.
Because then those
numbers were chosen
so that they give rise
to coefficients that
are equally visually distinct.
The result is that you
get very high resolution
with a very small
number of bits.
So here's an original.
This picture has 47
kilobytes of data in it.
And when you change
Q, the quality
of JPEG, what you're really
doing is choosing those tables.
So when you use a high Q, you
get a good representation.
When you use a low Q, you're
throwing away more data.
And you can see that
you can throw away--
so 47k down to 2k.
You can throw away 19
pieces of data out of 20
and you still get a very
good resolution picture.
And that's because the
quantization is happening
in the Fourier domain.
And you can match the
Fourier resolution better
to the psychophysical
properties of the eye.
So the point is to tell you
how to represent signals
in discrete time in a
way that the errors are
as imperceptible as possible.
And to demonstrate how
the Fourier transform
lets you do that.
OK, thanks.
See you later.